momo qui t'arrive bonne
tentant quelque chose ouais ouais oui
paris
est ce que ça va je comprends pas ce que
tu essaies de me dire
[Musique]
je t'entends
il faut postuler il faut vraiment qu'on
s'en aille s'il tablait respa larressore
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
joël sorte voiture
sardanes voiture
tu peux t'en sortir le lg
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui
[Musique]
ouais
ça va
[Musique]
tu vas bien
rien
bien tort de
lenny tueur de moutons
qu'est ce que
tu penses même à
jeter 10 10 kw à
paris
je t'interdis boys
ah ah
jusqu'à 5
[Musique]
waouh
ouais
y'a
bon c'était incroyable j'ai l'impression
d'être tom cruise
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
c'est trop cool ici
au plus tôt
ah [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
là
[Musique]
oh
l'europe
[Musique]
dana tu le chien
mais
[Musique]
non